[Applauso]
Buongiorno a tutti
Io sono Valentino ho dato
titolo
e oggi vi voglio parlare di passione
ma proiettata al futuro
vi voglio parlare di come è possibile
scrivere il proprio futuro
sembrerà strano
sembrerà impossibile
però vi voglio raccontare una storia di
passione
che è la mia storia
siamo abituati ad associare le passioni
ai sogni
quando cresciamo
cresciamo all'interno di un nucleo
familiare
che non scegliamo noi
ci ritroviamo all'interno di un nucleo
familiare
e crediamo che le persone che ci educano
alla vita
siano solo e soltanto i nostri genitori
Ma noi passiamo tra i 6 e i 19 anni
l'84% del nostro tempo quotidiano con
persone che non sono i nostri genitori
l'84% del nostro tempo quotidiano tra i
6 19 anni noi lo passiamo con i nostri
compagni di classe
con i nostri compagni
del nostro sport preferito con i nostri
professori
e con le persone che vivono con noi
alcune passioni che scegliamo perché
probabilmente seguiamo dei sogni
e comunemente ne associamo le passioni
associare i sogni a quello che riguarda
il mondo sportivo
e anch'io come tutti Ho iniziato a
seguire i miei sogni
nello sport
mi voglio far vedere un paio di foto e
voglio raccontare la mia storia di
passione
questo ero io
poi quello con il numero 21
è mio fratello
io ero quello lì davanti con il 19
e da piccolo nonostante io fossi in
panchina non era seduto in panchina
perché la passione era piccolino anche
nel basket era talmente forte da
sostituirmi all'allenatore
Avrò avuto 6 anni
poi Cresci
e capisci che la passione ti porta dei
risultati
io in questa foto
sono il numero 15
c'è stato un periodo della mia vita
in cui io ero chiamato lo sciocchino di
Vanzaghello
avevo otto anni
Shaquille Ninja giocava nei Lakers
avevo appena vinto il titolo con Kobe
Bryant
e io in quel momento della mia vita
giocava pallacanestro Vanzaghello ed ero
quello che faceva le contese iniziali
per chi conosce il basket La contesa è
l'inizio della partita
si alza la palla e tendenzialmente il
più alto il più grande e il più grosso
saltava per prendere la palla
e io ero quello delle contese
però per inseguire le passioni e i sogni
spesso ci sono imprevisti Ma ci sono
anche possibilità
E succede che spesso gli imprevisti non
te li sceglie
le possibilità a volte sì
Ma gli imprevisti no
sono lo stesso ragazzo
lo Shakira di Vanzaghello che ad un
certo punto della sua vita
tra gli 11 e 13 anni
scopre che qualcosa non funziona
e viene diagnosticata la malattia del
nanismo ipofisario
io sarei un nano e quindi ti rendi conto
che a quel punto
nell'anno in cui la tua vita cambia
e inizia a passare dalle scuole medie
alle scuole superiori
Tu sei quello che mentre i tuoi compagni
durante l'estate tornano a scuola 30 cm
più grandi di te tu torni a scuola e sei
lo stesso di quello del terza media
E allora Qualcosa deve cambiare
e da lì
che termina la fase dell'imprevisto
e inizia
a dare vita qualcosa
che si chiama idea
e quindi io ho iniziato a ragionare con
le idee su come poter continuare e
seguire la mia passione
che in quel momento di vita è sempre
stata comunque la pallacanestro
e allora ho iniziato a fare l'arbitro
che cosa mi permetteva di stare per
tutto il tempo di 40 minuti di una
partita sempre in campo l'arbitro
l'arbitro gioca sempre
e tu sempre
vivi quella esperienza
che sognavi da bambino Cioè quello di
essere al centro dell'esperienza
su un campo da basket perché quello era
il mio sogno
poi qualcosa
ti scatta e capisci che vuoi dare
qualcosa anche agli altri e quindi
l'idea della dell'essere arbitro Non
passa più allora nella squadra in cui
ero lo Shaquille di Vanzaghello divento
l'allenatore di futuri piccoli Shaquille
di Vanzaghello
però non bastava più
nel mentre cresco nel mentre continua il
mio percorso di scuola
diventa rappresentante d'istituto
E con questi quattro ragazzi noi quattro
ragazzi gli altri tre Matteo e Andrea
Riccardo decidiamo di affittare
la scuola
La Provincia ci concede di pagare un
prezzo agevolato e l'affitto della
scuola dalle 5 alle 11 di sera
dalle 5 alle 7 di sera facevamo studiare
i ragazzi che non potevano permettersi
delle ripetizioni private nelle aule
della scuola
prendevamo i ragazzi che erano usciti
come noi alle superiori e facevano il
primo anno di università per fare
ripetizioni
e non facevano ripetizioni 1-1 ma
facciamo un assistenza allo studio
aiutavano classi da 20 ragazze che non
potevano permettersi le petizioni
private di essere lì a scuola ripassare
e poi gli stessi ragazzi Però veniva
chiesto di fermarsi
e giocare a pallacanestro giocare a
pallavolo e rappresentare quella scuola
nella nostra società sportiva
l'idea
aveva fatto un passo in più
qui non ero più il giocatore o aspirante
tale non ero più l'arbitro non ero più
l'allenatore
divento presidente
e io con altri tre ragazzi a 19 anni
fondiamo la prima Polisportiva più
giovane d'Italia
Noi abbiamo fatto giocare
oltre 250 studenti di quella scuola
questo progetto è durato quattro anni
è diventata
una squadra in campionati più grandi e
non avevamo più solo i ragazzi della
scuola avevamo una vera prima squadra
vinciamo il campionato
Dopo quattro anni Io finalmente
vinco qualcosa
Quindi arriva un bivio
4 anni il progetto
ha funzionato il Ministero
dell'Istruzione Nel 2020 nel 2012
inserisce il progetto sport in Ticino un
bando da 100 milioni di euro contro la
dispersione scolastica
avevo due strade
o continuare
ad annaffiare quel piccolo quella
piccola pianta che stava prendendo vita
oppure tagliare tutto
Il problema è che quando insegui le
passioni
non sempre sei razionale
quando hai tante idee
non sempre si è razionale
e quindi ad un certo punto
insieme ad Andrea Matteo e Riccardo
decidiamo che
a vent'anni era giunto il momento
di
iniziare a pensare delle nuove idee ed
iniziare a dividerci
per cercare di riprendere in mano
un po' la nostra vita
cercare di capire che cosa era davvero
determinante per noi
cercare di capire se quella passione che
inseguivamo di una società sportiva che
avevamo portato al risultato che avevamo
la possibilità di fare diventare il
nostro futuro
perché era questo quello che ci avevano
chiesto dal ministero replicarlo in
oltre 2000 scuole italiane
Ma noi avevamo 22 anni
avevamo le competenze per farlo no
avevamo dei minuscoli al quale ispirarci
con i quali lavorare insieme che ci
davano fiducia nel sapere che la nostra
idea del nostro modello in quella scuola
portava gli stessi risultati con lo
stesso valore
e lo stesso impegno replicato in altre
2000 scuole no
eravamo troppo piccoli per pensarci
eravamo troppo piccoli per credere che
la nostra passione poteva diventare un
lavoro
o sarebbe potuto diventare il nostro
e quindi ad un certo punto
Ognuno di noi ha iniziato a lavorare
e io tra i 22 e 25 anni
ho iniziato a darmi dei micro obiettivi
dei micro obiettivi di 5 anni 5 anni io
nel mentre tra i 22 e i 25 anni
ho girato per il mondo
Sono stato a cena con Barack Obama
Sono stato a cena con Tim Cook
ho avuto una cena privata di tre ore con
il Premio Nobel per la pace o mamma news
io e altre 9 persone
ho incontrato i più grandi di questa
terra
Poi un giorno
nel 2019
lascio la mia azienda
Anzi lascio L'azienda che amavo
che mi ha cercato che mi ha voluto
che mi ha pagato
la lascio per inseguire una nuova
passione e io nel 2019 apro la mia
azienda
lavoro
non era passione per me era lavoro
e la mia azienda L'ho chiamata humans
io ho messo iOS perché in un incontro a
Chicago in una stanza di 30 persone
mentre parlavamo con Obama a fianco a me
c'era una ragazza di 32 anni
che dice
Quando è iniziata a parlare con le
persone non parlate mai di lavoro
la regola è iniziata con chi sei
iniziamo a parlare parliamo per due ore
e mezza non ci fermiamo mai mentre
facciamo un aperitivo
dopo due ore e mezza la domanda sul
lavoro arriva
io per due ore e mezza ho parlato con la
persona si chiamava catering maer aveva
quattro anni in più di me ed era
l'amministratore delegato mondo di
Wikipedia
amministratore delegato mondo di
Wikipedia c'è la persona
che in qualche modo detiene lo scibile
umano
e io torno a casa Torno a casa 2019 apre
l'azienda dal nome Yo masto humans e in
una settimana in cui io il lunedì dovevo
andare alle 5:30 del mattino ho preso un
treno per Milano
alle due del pomeriggio prendo il treno
per Bologna
alle 8 di sera a prendere il treno di
Bologna e tornare a casa
il martedì mattina a prendere un aereo e
andare a New York
mercoledì sera prende un aereo tornare
e l'incontro New York
Ieri sera tornavo il giovedì mattina
riprendevo un aereo e andava a Berlino a
Berlino incontravo Barack Obama stavo un
giorno
tornavo indietro sabato mattina prendere
un aereo la domenica avevo l'incontro
con Michelle Obama prendere domenica
sera e la settimana ripartiva io quella
mattina
succede qualcosa di strano
il 21 marzo del 2019 la mattina che mi
porta a Milano di quello lunedì mattina
Io incontro una persona
incontra Ilenia
lei
professoressa di matematica
la cosa bella
è che poi capisci
che
una passione da solo non la coltivi più
perché io in questo momento
da quando ho lasciato la mia passione
per la pallacanestro
non l'ho più inseguita
E allora ti rendi conto
che ad un certo punto della vita serve
qualcun altro per dar vita o a nuove
passioni
o far tornare in vita passioni nuove
perché
immaginate un puzzle
che è fatto di vari pezzi
pezzo Viola pezzo bianco
poi c'è un cuore
e questa è la nostra nuova passione
tre mesi fa è nato Michelangelo
E questa
è la forza
di un incontro tra persone che possono
generare nuove passioni
Grazie
[Applauso]